the fundamental theorem of algebra
fundamental
i'll write it out theorem
theorem of
algebra
tells us that if we have an nth degree
polynomial so let's write it out so
let's say i have let's say i have the
function p of x and it's an it's defined
by an nth degree polynomial so let's say
it's a
x to the n plus b x to the n minus one
and you just go all the way to some
constant term at the end so this is an
nth degree polynomial the fundamental
theorem of algebra tells us that this
nth degree polynomial is going to have n
exactly n roots
n
roots or another way to think about it
they're going to be exactly n values for
x which will make this polynomial make
this expression on the right be equal to
zero
so at first you might say okay that
makes sense you've seen second degree
second degree polynomials whose graphs
might look something like this
so
so let's say it's the y-axis that's the
x-axis
we know a second-degree polynomial would
define a parabola so it might look
something like this
and you could buy that okay this is a
second degree
that's second
degree
and you see that this function equals a
zero exactly two places it has exactly
it has exactly two roots
it has
two roots so that seems consistent with
the fundamental theorem of algebra and
you could also imagine a third degree
polynomial looking like this
so that's my y-axis this is my
x-axis you could imagine a third degree
polynomial looking something like this
bam bam bam and it just keeps going and
here you see it's third degree
polynomial and you'll see it has one
two
three roots and i could have a fourth
degree polynomial that maybe it looks
something like this where it goes
something like
this and you say okay that makes sense
it'll have one two
three four roots but then you might
start to remember things that don't
always behave in this way for example
many many many many times we've seen
parabolas we've seen second degree
polynomials that look more like this
where they don't seem to intersect the
x-axis
so this seems
to seems to conflict with the
fundamental theorem of algebra the
fundamental theorem of algebra says if
we have a second degree
second degree polynomial then we should
have
exactly
two roots
now this is the key
the fundamental theorem of algebra it
extends
our number system we're not just talking
about real roots we're talking about
complex roots and in particular the
fundamental theorem of algebra allows
even these coefficients to be complex
and so when we're looking at these these
first examples these were all real roots
and real numbers are a subset of complex
numbers so here you had two real roots
here you had three real roots in this
orange function you had four
real roots in this yellow function this
yellow parabola right over here the
second degree polynomial we have no real
roots that's why you don't see it
intersecting the x-axis but we will have
two complex roots so this one right over
here will have
two
complex
two complex roots and the complex roots
the the non-real complex roots because
really real numbers are a subset of
complex numbers these always come in
pairs and we'll see that in future
videos so for example if you have if you
have a third degree polynomial it might
look something like this
a third degree polynomial might look
something like this
where it has
one real root
but then the fundamental theorem of
algebra tells us it necessarily has two
other roots because it is a third
third degree so we know that the other
two roots must be
non-real complex roots now could you
have a situation where you have a third
degree polynomial with three complex
roots so can you have three
non-non-real
complex
non-real complex roots is this possible
for a third degree polynomial
well the answer is no because complex
roots as we'll see in the next few
videos
always come in pairs that they're coming
in pairs where they are conjugates of
each other so you could have you could
have a fourth degree
you could have a fourth degree
polynomial that has no real roots for
example something might look something
like this
in this case you would have two pairs of
complex roots or you would have four
non-real complex roots and you could
group them into two pairs where in each
pair you have conjugates and we'll see
that in the next video